i thought it's such a piece of trash
what a stupid idea and it did a ton
i'm going to go to every beach on earth
i just want to go to every beach on
earth
and i did it took me three years and at
the end of it
i was bored out of my [ __ ] mind i
mean i just said
this sucks the industry that mines
bitcoin specifically needs to find a
voice
to talk about the things they do that
actually help build sustainability into
energy
i've seen you multiple times riding your
bicycle we've gone to dinner you've
ridden
the mr wonderful bike there yeah did you
recover it somebody stole it
so it got stolen in a big uh
big operation they stole over 100 bikes
that night in vespas
oh so this was not a targeted no crime
well i found out later
um it and i offered a 25 000 reward not
for the bike
you know i wanted to catch the guy that
did it so their
organized crime organization and they
put in a truck and they put the truck on
a barge in the river
and they took maybe 250 bikes that night
off the streets of miami
and what do they do with them uh they
apparently sell them they take them
offshore
they put it on a ship and just so my mr
wonderful is in some south american
country right now
and vivalo the bike company that made it
for me uh saw it on social media and
said let's do another one even crazier
so i was there last week designing the
craziest miami bike you've ever seen
it's pink it's red it's black i'll have
it though it's going to
when you see it i'm going to be mr
wonderful ala miami
all right uh i feel like you've done a
great job
shark tank all the social media uh cnbc
etc you've built this massive audience
yeah
uh how do you think about that stuff
versus like the investing activity do
you still spend a lot of time
investing or is it more so now you've
got the investments you've got you've
made those investments and now it's more
of the the media focus and kind of the
content
i think a new model is emerging and
you're actually part of this new model
and let me explain
the way i see it over the last 24 months
so
let's take a company that is trading
mind med when i got approached with that
uh company here in miami at the soho
club second floor
it was a bunch of crypto guys three
years ago one guy there
named j.r rand said look i'm a
kryptonian however
i also have a great interest in
psychedelics as medicine i said you're
crazy those are illegal drugs lsd is
illegal schedule 1 narcotics same as
cannabis
psilocybin all of this stuff he said no
no i'm going to go to the fda
form a company and do clinical trials
there's no recreational use of this
and you know i want three million bucks
and i said you know it's too crazy but
i'm gonna my guy alex
um who does runs older adventures he's
got a team we'll do due diligence on it
it's intriguing enough
that was three years ago alex worked on
it for about two months
and he really went to town on it and did
a lot of research with his guys
and the way my deal with alex works to
give you an idea
of how this works i probably told you i
already know but go ahead okay so
when we do an investment you know i'm
the bank
i lend him 15 percent so his you know
what's her on the line he borrows the
money for me and he invests beside me he
gets his own stock but he owes me the
doe
15 so that i know our interests are
aligned
this is the first time in history on
mind mid where he came back to me and
said i'm taking your 15
and i'm tripling it with my own dough
and i went what
why and he laid out his case we ended up
investing that went from a 20 million
20 million valuation that we bought in
at to now 1.7 billion so it's my biggest
winner in years uh but those are the
kind of investments and how did that
story happen
this is where social media intersected
with the story of mind mid
it got into the rolling stone it was in
you know all the news magazines it was
in the popular press it was all over
social media
because i was talking about along with
all the other advocates and the story
built into a giant company that has over
300 000 shareholders so my new model
pomp is this
you want me to get involved in your
business all right i want a proprietary
position i don't care what your last
round was at i want to be a founder so
you're going to give up in stock
but then i'm going to turn on my machine
and if you have
a story of merit i will explain it to
other shareholders and hopefully we'll
build this business together
using all the tools the new world has
shows like this
social media yahoo finance benzingo cnbc
cnn abc that's how companies get to be
known
not just for shareholders to tell their
product story
why should you care about microdosing
lsd because it works or at least it
potentially can
and it's going through clinical trials
and it can solve for
you know addiction opioid addiction
anxiety
alcoholism all these things is there a
specific type of company that this works
for
more so than other types of companies
like does it have to have some inherent
story behind it and some interest and
that's really what you're trying to
underwrite just as much as the actual
investment itself
it's a great question but the truth is
every company has to be able to tell
their story in the best light i don't
care if it's really sophisticated
technology i mean it's much better when
it's consumer good or service but
right now the reason crypto is of such
interest globally is the story was told
by guys like you for years
and it slowly emerged as a story of you
know store of wealth if you want to call
it that or currency if you want to call
it that whatever it was
it's the fact that investing has become
democratized by the robin hoods by the
reddit crowd by all the
news channels by the cable channels
business is part of
everyday news every day and so if you
can get a following that is interested
in your investment philosophy i invest
sustainably ethically that's what i do
that's where i came from that's all i do
and people that are interested in that
follow they don't have to invest with me
they don't have to they can bet against
me
but at least they hear these company's
stories so my argument is
that the value i have to a company now
is the ability to take its story and
blow it
up and then investors will make their
own individual decisions
but that's very hard to get to that
place and it's taken me a long time as
it has taken you
and i want to use that power wisely when
you think about public markets versus
private markets
how much of this is better suited for
public markets where there's
liquid stock price they're shareholders
people can make decisions every day buy
sell hold whatever versus the private
market where
there's not so much access for some
investors right there's not that liquid
kind of daily stock price and maybe the
impact is more around like helping the
business built
in terms of getting customers or driving
you know consumers to check it out or
whatever
is it either or or can this work across
both public and private markets
it's both and the most powerful platform
to tie these together
is equity you know crowdfunding now
where you can tell a consumer of a
product or service that you can become a
shareholder at the same time i'm very
intrigued by that i have a relationship
with start engine now
one of the largest crowdfunding
platforms in the world so when a company
has
a hundred thousand customers that have
tried its product is still private
we can go to the customers and say look
you love our product you love our
service now we're going public you can
buy our shares
you can buy them online you can put two
hundred dollars or two thousand dollars
or twenty thousand dollars
into the company that you've been
supporting now for five years and that's
this is again another digital you know
crossroads
of equity and funding and debt to the
consumer
which doesn't have the same issue around
timing like a private equity firm does
or a venture capital firm where after
seven years they turn into a pumpkin
and they want to prep share and they
want this and they want all these
special rights
i'm not into that anymore i'd rather do
you want to raise 50 million let's do it
in equity crowdfunding where everybody
owns the same share all the interests
are aligned there's no time bomb
people can buy and sell their stock
anytime they want and so for me
um it again goes to the platform what i
try and do with my companies that are
private is get them customer acquisition
costs get theirs down
and i use my platforms to talk about
their products and services i
try to get people to try the products
but you know at the end of the day
um i feel a responsibility i don't
endorse products i don't use personally
i think that's [ __ ]
and i think people can smell [ __ ] a
mile away so i never do that
you know i do things that i use i like
or i invest in and i tell my story and
you can either agree or disagree it's
but at least i get that mega bull horn
to get out there and talk about it
yeah when you think about your career
building up the media side there's a lot
of people who listen who they're very
interested in this and more so
founders are interested in this as well
so one of the big secrets in
venture capital right now is almost on a
daily basis i have a founder that comes
to me and says how do i build my twitter
following how do i build facebook how do
i build instagram you know
should i create an email newsletter like
what should i do so that i have the same
power maybe it's at a smaller scale
but i can talk directly to an audience
uh that's in my vertical
or in my industry and i think that
there's a lot of um kind of value that
can accrue there
what are the things that you did that
you're like these were the big
inflection points right obviously shark
tank probably was a big one but are
there other things that you're like
this is how i built this massive
platform and kind of made a name for
yourself
where people were willing to at least
listen hear you out
what i found worked as these you know
it's a it's a complex question because i
get the same question all the time how
can i get
a million followers well it's not that
easy i mean there's people that try and
sell you services to do it there's all
kinds of consultants that try and do it
for you
they want you to pay them 15 grand a
month all that stuff happens but the
truth is
that social media is is the great
democratizer of people that are good
storytellers
because if you have interesting
information that may assist somebody
or they may find interesting they will
tell another
about it they will send that link to
somebody else and that actually
that organic growth occurred pretty
quickly for me it started you know fifty
thousand a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand
then a million and then another million
it and i never changed i mean i like to
have fun on social
media you know i'll play guitar with my
pajamas on saturday i'm happy to do that
um people play guitar like to do that
but you know just share it
i talk about stocks i talk about bonds i
get very very serious about issues
around politics
i just laid out there and it's all true
and i don't [ __ ]
and i think that's what worked for me
but i'm very happy to be in different
verticals
you know i can talk about watches with
anybody in the world now i have a
massive watch collection
i used to be a shareholder offender i
can play guitar
i have chef wonderful as a multi-million
dollar business now my wine business
is now the largest direct consumer in
the country really yeah
yeah we just did 5.1 million in 20 hours
on qvc last week that's an all-time
record so these are different verticals
that interest me
and there's different constituents that
come into your universe
around those interests i got a huge
following of people that like wine
tell me more about the wine business i
don't know anything about this yeah so
you know here's something interesting
that i learned i
i grew up uh with a swiss stepfather
who's really
taught me in my teenage years how to uh
you know the difference between bordeaux
and burgundy and drc and
the italian wines and all the varietals
and i became interested
and over in europe you know wine is just
part of family
it's not about getting drunk over there
they just drink it you know maybe one
glass or two glasses not a big deal
so kids drink it watered down whatever
and so i became pretty proficient at the
varietals i always was interested in why
you know i'm a collector of wine and an
investor i buy wine futures with a group
in boston we invest millions of dollars
in wine
and we try and guess which varietals
like this year's gonna be terrible
because it snowed just last week
in in france it actually snowed it's
it's unprecedented
and the point is when you get
knowledgeable about it you get
it's kind of sucked into that lifestyle
so i started
a wine business in california where i
blended it and i sold it
and um i was losing money like everybody
else
like a lot of money everybody goes into
it romantically and i'll joke if you
want to be a millionaire start as a
billionaire in the wine business
because you lose a ton of money and then
i met this woman
through shark tank named annette alvarez
she was the wine buyer for costco the
largest buyer of wine in the world is
costco people don't understand that
all the global wines they are the
largest seller of wines as well
i was trying to sell her a shark tank
deal of single serve wines
nobody could ever reach her she was
impossible to get to and i asked one of
the guys in my office to go to the dark
web and hack her cell number
which i had in 10 minutes and i called
it and i left a message
and um i said listen i'm the guy on
shark tank
if you're a shark tank fan i don't know
you saw that deal last night
a single serve wine deal cuban and i
went into and i'd love you to costco
to uh this is the cupola wine or
whatever it was it was the
yeah and there was another one called
zips as well and so i left the
um the message and i thought well maybe
she'll call me back 10 minutes later
i was up at our lake house the phone
rang and said this is annette alvarez
i got your message you were rude to
barbara last night
on shark day i went what what
she said no you're really rude to her
and i said i gotta tell you something
annette um the only reason barbara gets
the shark tank on time is i buy her new
broom every year
and she didn't think that was a funny
joke but we were over two with them yeah
i know i thought she'd like that but she
didn't and and anyways we got into a
conversation she
said i'm on my way to hawaii for our
annual holiday with my husband
i'll be at john wayne airport at one
o'clock on saturday
it was thursday night and uh if you want
to fly here to meet me you can bring
your wife because i want to meet your
wife too
i said why she said i just do and i want
to see a real person
and i said linda we're going to uh john
wayne and we flew there i got an hour of
her time and she told me this she said
look
you want to sell wine with me i'm the
largest buyer on earth
the only reason you get this hour with
me is i'm a huge shark tank fan i have
some questions about the show i'd like
to meet you it's great
but here's what you need to know about
the wine business 97 percent of wine
sold in america
is sold for under 14 a bottle
97 percent people don't understand that
that's all of the wine pump
that's basically the stuff you buy for
60 bucks you're in the three percent
in order for you to make money you're
going to have to be able to ship me 150
000 cases a day if i order a cab from
you i need 150 000 cases that's just my
stocking order
the next day i meet another hundred
thousand you can't do that you don't
have the capabilities you don't have the
logistics you can't even understand how
much juice that is
if you want to pull that off i'm going
to give you the name of a guy named pat
roney
he owns 19 vineyards and he makes our
kirkland wine he
is our logistics guy he can ship me 2
million cases
you form a wine company with him you go
50 50 partnership then i know you have
the logistics skills then
then i'll give you an order and it'll
blow your socks off how much wine we can
buy from you
i go to see pat and pat says
i know you're coming and that called me
we're interested let's format a
relationship
we fought for six months on the terms of
it it ended up being 50 50.
um it has been wildly successful
because she was right the minute we
dropped our price point between 11 and
14 we started selling
you know hundreds of thousands of cases
and last week i broke a record never
been done before on qvc we sold
5.125 million dollars worth of wine in
21 hours
that means we have to ship a quarter of
a million cases in two days we can do it
but that's a business that's very
profitable now in fact a spac
took over um that company i'm now a
shareholder in uh vintage wine estates
and it's going to trade on the nasdaq
june 6th
wow yeah and so uh you also do direct to
consumer as well or it's just
absolutely launching a new site i'll be
announced next week so i'm a little
early on it here called shop mr
wonderful and it's going to have not
only all my wines but all my shark tank
products
so a massive play direct to consumer as
a result of the pandemic
organized by a great digital team a lot
of work going into this
it's it's like extending the voice pomp
as we talked about the beginning of the
show i you know what do i do with this
voice
these are products i invested in i use
wines
i make my wife blends the whites i do
the reds
this is our family stuff try it it's a
very it's it's an honest
pitch if you don't like the wines ship
it back i mean you know you can send it
back if you want but
when it comes to wine i've got your back
nobody makes wine like i do yeah
uh crypto i think when we first met uh
three years ago maybe now yeah uh cnbc
set
i didn't know very much about you other
than how this guy on shark tank yeah
uh i don't think you knew anything about
me and i told you that 50
of my net worth in bitcoin i thought you
were [ __ ] crazy and
uh well that that's a nice way of
putting it because i think on the
segment what you said was i forbid you
from
i for being i remember we were on the
set of squawk boxes
and i thought who is this idiot yes why
would he put so much into one thing
and uh and you didn't realize that uh
i think i was playing a game with you
and you were playing a game with me
because
right before the segment started uh they
were at commercial and we were all
talking or whatever
and uh i was just kind of jabbing you a
little bit trying to get you to
to be excited and then you you said to
me right before straight how much you
know do you have in this i said 50
the lights cameras turn on and that was
the first thing you fired across
well i mean those that was then and but
in 2017
i had nibbled in i'd start buying some
bitcoin and some
um you know ethereum at that time
and a couple of other i think u.s i
can't remember when i bought my stable
coins but
you know what happened to me it because
i'm in a highly regulated industry with
you know
all my indexing and all these financial
services companies that i've invested in
so i'm really regulated by the
regulators and i started talking about
crypto and whoa what a negative response
back then you remember
it was it was especially 2018 when it
had dropped from
20 000 bitcoin price to 3 200 so i got
my wings clipped pretty
pretty hard by lawyers in washington
saying you got to stop i mean you know
you're a heavily regulated guy and
you're out there on tv talking about
bitcoin forget it
and you talk about as much as you want
or not but like
i think a lot of people think uh elon
tweets something or there's somebody who
is really bullish who also
is a little bit more bearish and they
call the tap on the shoulder right
the like hey knock it off type thing
yeah is that like a
you know goes through the back door
conversations someone just says hey you
know you should chill with that or is
that like
something that is uh kind of more uh
stated
right in terms of the way it works is i
i
i have to be compliant as per the
compliance officers that work in these
companies
every single word i say including this
this podcast is going to be
reviewed by compliance and these are
organizations i have to be compliant
with
because they have to be they're telling
the regulators that we are compliant and
they have to make sure that's their job
and so i started getting calls from lots
of them in different companies saying
you're way offside
and you've got to stop and i did and i
you know um what happened though
if only it was only eight months ago
when the swiss regulator the french
regulator the german uh
new zealand uh brent britain switzerland
and canada they started putting etfs out
the regulators had gone 360 or 180
whatever you call it right
and i said well wait a second i'm an
investor in those jurisdictions i have
investments in all those jurisdictions
i'm a global investor i have them
investments in all those currencies
i am going to buy some um
bitcoin as i can in in those
jurisdictions we don't have it here yet
the same way but it's coming i would
assume
and obviously the regulators have lifted
their their curtain or
made it easier to do that and so i
started um
growing my position to three percent
i'm a five in the operating company so
we have five percent in gold for example
i said let's go crypto uh to three and
we started buying coins and we started
buying ether and we started you know
investing in a few other things
and then i started getting calls and i
think i've talked to you about this
i service uh institutional clients and
sovereign funds
and they they saw me on cnbc talking
about my three percent waiting
and the phone lit up it went nuts
and what was it about it was about esg
it was about this issue around
sustainability
and saying where'd your coin come from
but they were mine in china i said well
who cares it's all fungible coin it's
bitcoin's a bitcoin it's awarded it's a
coin they said well we're you're
supporting cold by
coal burning uh miners you know this
issue i predicted would explode and i
think i've been right on that thing but
it hasn't changed my
interest in uh you know going long
bitcoin for a bunch of reasons because
i've gotten a lot more sophisticated now
what interests me the most right now is
defy i think it's where the puck is
going and i'll tell you why
so now i've got a large amount of
capital tied up three percent weighting
in the operating companies a lot of
capital
and it's not yielding anything right so
why don't
so i said to my guys let's get into some
d5 and take a portion of the assets
and wrap it into the ethereum chain and
let's start making some interest
let's start looking at different ways
that we can loan our our assets out
and start making four five six seven
eight you know i've talked about this
i have gotten way down that rabbit hole
and and i'm
way deep into that now let's stop for a
second just some people understand where
we are so you got three percent
of operating company assets right in
crypto you've got five percent in gold
uh first question is
why still five percent gold three
percent crypto uh i think a lot of
people who've kind of gone down the
rabbit hole of crypto
either invert that right so it's five
percent crypto three percent gold or
like literally have gotten rid of the
gold
so why still have more gold than crypto
right now you know that
it's a great question and we've had that
discussion internally every we do our
our meetings uh every monday at 10
o'clock we review the portfolio changes
et cetera
uh i know there's going to be a change
there soon because it comes up every
monday now
okay because we can't make any interest
off gold and we now are starting to get
yield
and starting to make money and and the
weird thing as you well know
we've had tremendous volatility in
bitcoin this last 10 days
that actually enhances d5 it makes it
better i'm making way more on my
contracts now
and so you know i said to the guys look
um and this is you know brad this is i
haven't even told anybody this story
it's just unique it's on your
podcast because it's so new um you only
bring me the good story well you know we
talk about a lot of stuff so
i said to the guys on my crypto team
look um this d5 stuff is really
complicated it is not easy you know
we've got a metamask format we've got
all of these other platforms all the
stuff we have to do these contracts
this is crazy complicated but there must
be millions of people that have a little
bit of coin that want to make some four
or five six percent on it why don't you
go find me
a company a team
that i can invest in that will do a
commercialized d5 and i mean not not
corporate
so that somebody that has a wallet
that's got maybe you know 20 grand or 10
or 5 thousand dollars in it
could easily do what i'm doing that
takes a staff of four people
you're basically talking about more
user-friendly
better user experience an easy way hey i
elect i want to do this
and rather than me actually have to go
in and do it myself i can
use this service to accomplish this yeah
and so they came up with this team again
it's in a different jurisdiction because
it's canada which is very open these
days
a vancouver team that one of my crypto
guys uh introduced me to
ben is the uh you know and he's got a
great
almost 20 people there doing this that
they're all ex-bankers they understand
the whole format they're
they're deep deep deep into the
algorithms and all the code they're
writing
and they said look we're looking to
raise some money here um
uh do you want to be an investor and i
said yeah i'll take this on
i'll i'll uh but i want to buy a third
of the company i want to be a
significant shareholder
and we negotiated for a while because
you're going to be you're going to do
two things for me i'm going to help your
company but i'm going to give you a ton
of capital
and you're going to manage it according
to the way i want to manage it and
you're going to produce things that i
want because i know if i want them
others are going to want them like tax
returns
i want to press a button get a tax
return i don't i want to be compliant
right
nobody does that yet i don't want to
have to sit there with an account and
figure out all my trades i want to
automatically produce
he's working on that his team is working
on that so we put
um we put a significant round together
for them a 20 million dollar round
um i'm the lead on that thing and uh
uh i think it's going to be a great
company we haven't even announced it yet
it's
it's called d5 ventures um i'm going to
rename it to wonderfi
because it's it's going to be my my
vehicle
and um i think it's just the beginning
you know some great things to come
and uh so when you go into d5 what
exactly are you guys doing you're taking
bitcoin that you own and ether and ernie
so there must be many other investors
like me i've made my decision to three
to five percent allocation
probably as you as you snuck out of me
i'm going to be moving it up because
you're right gold's not doing anything
for me well three plus five is eight
not five so you could get rid of all
that gold could get to ten
okay all right but you know we're bound
by certain covenants just for how we
manage the operating company
ten i feel like is on the upper bound of
most conservative investors right so it
still fits within the
kind of bands if you will if you're a
conservative investor most of your focus
is outside of crypto
yeah one to ten percent is kind of the
ban is up there bob
it's five percent institutional investor
ten is up there of course
right now that number for the big guys
is three percent they're happy and they
they want bitcoin they haven't gotten
past that yet
bitcoin is the property the digital
asset they want
um and they want to store value store
value and you've been right on that
can't deny that okay it's a it's a
volleyball
we might have to roll the tape back and
they have to erase that but
my whole point is the the it it has
inherent volatility but imagine
so here's my thoughts about d5 okay i've
got the vol i know i'm going to be
up up and down 38 a year that's what
it's been historically right
so we're seeing that we've had a crazy
vault right here we're literally
recording this on a day that uh
it's been down 40 in a month okay so so
let's say in in my case my defy company
of which i'm a large shareholder now i
say to the guys look
let's put a bunch of crypto on our
balance sheet
all right i'm going to own a third of
that balance sheet or whatever i own of
the balance sheet
i want you to loan that out and get me
between a four and a half and an eight
percent yield
now of course i have to mark to market
the change in value
because it's going up and down but i'm
kind of agnostic because i'm owning it
as property i don't
really care because it's an allocation
let's say it's five percent
it's going to stay at five i'll change
it every quarter adding and taking away
from it
but i want you to loan it out there so
the whole
operation the defy operation is to start
doing these contracts for me on an ai
basis
so it can go look to the market see what
the spreads are on all these different
opportunities i don't want to get too
complicated with it
it's basically yield farming what you're
just going to do is yield it and then
others that are interested like i am on
taking their asset
and imagine if i could have over these
years had a five percent yield on my
gold
that would have been incredible well i
can on my crypto so
that's really what i'm doing in d5 and i
think i've got the best team in north
america everybody says that but
i'm backing this team because i've done
a lot of due diligence on them
and um i i think you know in the next
few months
that will become part of our portfolio
with a yield metric to it
so because what you're basically saying
is uh you're going to keep the assets
denominated
in the asset right so uh let's say just
freezing
things you have a hundred eth you put
that in you want eight percent so now
you're gonna end the year with a hundred
and eight eight
staying in regardless of did the price
go up or down
i might go back to fiat to just pay some
expenses but i'm going to stay and eat
on that balance sheet and you as a
shareholder
go with me in the share price as my
assets grow
do you think that this is a really
important piece that i think the
traditional world hasn't woken up to yet
sounds like you're now
getting there is um once you leave fiat
into crypto
yeah you don't go back i don't want to
go back okay why would i
well i don't know you tell me how do you
think about it right so you've got
100 of your assets you said i'm gonna
take three i'm gonna put it into crypto
yeah uh maybe that goes up maybe it
doesn't whatever but let's just say it's
three to five percent whatever the
allocation is
once you put that into crypto why are
you not going back well the reason i
would come back out let's say
let's say our covenant is a max on 10
which at that most institution that is
max arena okay all right so 10 is the
max allocation because because if you're
going
you know you basically if you have lps
or you have other shareholders or you
have
other constituents you've told them you
have a covenant of diversification and
it might be 10
whatever it is but it's not much higher
than that so when you get to 12
at the end of a quarter in your crypto
you're going to trim back to fiat
you're going to go back to 10 percent or
or maybe you know
um and then you just sit in the weeds
waiting for correction and you buy back
up to 10 percent i you know i've been
buying
like i mean you bought the dip well it's
it's it's not really a dip it's
maintaining the three percent weighting
right
yeah no i'm saying the dip in the price
i know i know but it but to me it's okay
we're 2.4 and we said we're a three buy
up to three
because we've had a correction you can't
call that that's a correction
well i mean look in 2017 there was what
six over thirty percent i think right
there was two forty percent drawdown so
uh it doesn't feel good right
draws down but it's not uh atypical for
the
kind of historical bull runs right right
which again if you tell in the
traditional world
uh hey there's gonna be two forty
percent drawdowns but you're gonna go up
20 x in a year
they're like i'm out well yeah like i'm
out of this
but but in this case um you end up with
more coin after that correction
and then you're out loaning it out and
you're getting your and with that
volatility you just got 200 bases points
more yield
people don't understand vol is good for
yield it's not good for your stomach
but it actually helps you mine yield
from your crypto
and so when you understand those smart
contracts and how it's being loaned out
um and i'm getting way more
sophisticated so i look at it now
with my team saying okay you know you
could even put leverage on this if you
want which we don't
but i think that's a crazy chicken move
but you could really gucci why are you
only targeting four and a half to eight
percent some of these
can pay twenty percent what's your
duration
what duration well that's why i'm asking
you right is it just you're saying hey i
want to be able to earn the four and a
half to eight percent forever
and the 20 to 30 is only there for a
couple of weeks or a couple of months
like
how do you think about yield verse
duration so what we don't have is a long
history of what that curve on duration
looks like you just don't have it we're
all
pioneers in this and because i'm a bond
guy i've been a bond guy for decades and
so what i look at is duration and
quality
you don't you can't work with that yet
we don't know so i said look let's keep
our contract short let's understand
the change in the deltas let's
understand you know how inefficient the
market is when there's a lot of
volatility let's just
gather our own data keep our powder dry
let's only loan out 50 of our positions
until we understand it works
and i should also disclose i'm working
with some of the larger
corporate defy guys i've opened accounts
to manage some of my company's balance
sheets i'm putting up to five percent of
our
fiat currency into a strategy like this
on our balance sheets
i don't talk about that too much but i'm
letting you know i'm saying guys
we're in you know let's have an
operating company it's sitting with you
know
30 million dollars in cash let's put
million and a half
into this strategy we'll open an account
you'll understand it works you're the
treasury let me show you how it works
how i'm doing it
let's disclose to uh if they're private
we just have to disclose to our lp's
what we're doing
i haven't anybody said to me no i don't
want that everybody wants to learn
so instead of making nothing on our cash
which we're basically under inflation
we're losing money on our cash
you know we're picking up we're doing
better than four and a half that was a
few weeks ago when coin was very stable
now like today you can get seven eight
nine
as you know mm-hmm so it's not
impossible and so i think
why i only put five percent of the
company's assets why not do more if
it's just yield you're not taking the
price risk necessarily in terms of
that's the goal
because the compliance um
departments are all in that let's tiptoe
in
you you know the the concern it's it it
really
is a three percent number right now
there are some at five
but here's the thing that everybody
should understand that i because i live
in this world
the potential is huge you've got
less than one percent of
of global corporations even thinking
about crypto right now
so as time passes and they see examples
of what i'm doing and others are doing
and they start to tiptoe in you're
talking about
billions of dollars that are sitting on
balance sheets making nothing and so
it's going to become
that's good and bad news because the
more money goes into that the less yield
you're going to be making there's going
to be a lot of competition
and so but right now i'm tiptoeing
through the tulips you know
almost double-digit yields i think it
comes down commensurate with the
volatility so you here's the thing to
understand i don't want to get too
complicated but let's say when you put a
lot of bitcoin on your balance sheet
you're gonna have vol you're gonna have
volatility the criticism of tesla we've
been watching
they showed on cnbc today all the
balance sheets that have
you know crypto on it they're all down
because people are like oh whoa was me
they've got crypto it's going to affect
their balance sheet
it does but at the same time they're
loaning it out
if they're smart and they're bringing in
yield that they never used to make on
their cash
so over time when people understand this
it'll offset it
i think people when they hear this are
going to be very surprised to hear that
you're buying the dip
you're getting into d5 you're earning
yield right those are uh
various um fairly sophisticated
strategies
compared to just by bitcoin right or uh
hey i want to buy a mining stock for
example
because you're getting more and more in
the weeds right over the last like two
years maybe went from
uh hey i probably shouldn't talk that
much about this okay maybe there's
something interesting to three percent
now like hey let's start going further
and further into the weeds
where does this go like 10 years from
now like if you just fast forward and
you say okay hold on a second like
there's a bunch of stuff that has to get
built and get there
eventually it's just 100 of corporate
balance sheets or you know in digital
assets and so there's digital dollars
but also bitcoin ether whatever
there's yield there's like all like a
true decentralized financial system that
gets built here kind of right out
underneath of wall street or is there
coexistence or like
just like where are we going i guess i
guess what's happening
is the money is looking for the most
frictionless way
to actually be productive and so the
reason um
d5 is so interesting instead of paying
those crazy 200 bases to two percent
fees that these wallets are charging
i don't need those guys for anything
maybe i need a ramp to put my fiat into
ether or whatever
but after that i don't need them and i
can go and do this for a fraction of
those costs on a decentralized basis
what got me into this was we're always
trying to find a place for our cash
like when we haven't found an investment
we want some kind of yield on our cash
and right now we have a lot of cash
because we sold a lot of commercial real
estate during
just before the pandemic and during it
because i'm worried about what happens
to all that
office tower space i'm not sure
everybody's coming back the way they
think
so one of the guys that works with alex
that runs all their adventures was one
of our interns
heavy crypto eric's name i'm not going
to tell you a second name so nobody bugs
them but
he came to me and said listen you got a
ton of cash here
why don't we start a fund a structured
product
that does exactly what we've been
talking about and i said why is it going
to be structured product he said because
in the jurisdiction we're going to put
the fund where you're going to invest
the cash
they allow this they don't allow it here
in the us yet but there's other
jurisdictions like switzerland and
everywhere else
and you and you just report your gains
to the irs as you said any other asset
and he worked on it he went way down the
rabbit hole on it
and he's still working on it it may
still come to pass but in the meantime i
said to him
eric why don't you and alice go find me
a company that's doing this already
i don't need to have a fund i got the
cash let's just
buy the company and put our cash on the
balance sheet if we're a large enough
shareholder
we won't care and uh is which is what we
did and he
so he found the company he introduced me
to these guys in vancouver you know uh
d5 ventures
and i met the ceo and the whole team and
i went wow and i showed other investors
the team and said hey guys do you want
to come in with me
put this deal together and that's that's
actually how it happened
and along the way uh you know i ran into
guys you know josh richards his partner
animal ventures all those guys
we all looked at it together and said
this is cool so we're partners on it
i think it's great i mean and he you
know he
josh is like some phenom you know gen
z guy that wants to be part of this and
so i said okay
who's better at picking stocks you were
josh we did it
we did it with wine the other day and he
shouldn't even be drinking
he's only 19. but i met his parents
online he's a great cool kid and and uh
you know griff his partner
and mike michael gruen and all those
guys we have fun together
and uh i actually introduced them to the
crew at cnbc and i said you got to get
this guy on as the gen
z guy like you're the crypto guy i'm the
institutional guy
he should be the gen z guy he's very
smart
i i like him and i said you know you
want to come into a couple of deals with
me let's work together and find some
stuff
and he's been backed by some heavy
hitters you know yeah oh yeah
i i know the whole story um i think part
of uh what's so fascinating is
uh you have a lot of different worlds
that collide right so you've got
wine you've got watches you've got shark
tank you've got uh
commercial real estate you've got your
traditional kind of businesses
and investing uh venture capital and
then you've also got crypto
yeah and when all that comes together is
it fair just to say like you're just
looking for the best opportunities
you would be right but you know i'm like
you
i want to enjoy what i'm doing i want to
get up in the day and say
everything that nancy's plotted for this
day including being here with you i want
to do it i don't want to do stuff
i don't have to do anything but i want
to do stuff
and i love working with entrepreneurs i
just i like finding people and saying
look don't do that because i've
been there before it's a mistake do this
or i can help you here i can help you
here
and let me come along for the ride and
let me bring in shareholders vest beside
me and let's do stuff together
i have a community of entrepreneurs that
enjoy like you know
i work all day and all night and i love
what i do when i get up and play the
guitar in the middle of the night i
was wailing out in the balcony the other
day at like two in the morning i know
they're pissed at me on the beach
but it was just fun for a couple of
minutes you just enjoyed it i enjoyed it
and so that that kind of you know it's
it's like uh
live your life because as if there won't
be another tomorrow
and try and make some money because it's
expensive can i ask you a uh somewhat
personal question sure i've never asked
you this before
do you have like a number in mind that
you would eventually say you know what
i've had my fun but like
i am now rich enough where like i want
to walk away is there
a milestone or is it literally
you're gonna die working and you'll just
never retire you'll never
stop i'm not working for money anymore i
don't need any more i don't want to lose
what i've got
and there's always another watch to buy
and so you know every
the the reason i do deals is in my world
you have to do a deal to buy a watch so
you remember what deal
that watch was from and that's the
collection so i'm always doing deals to
buy watches
that's basically the way i look at it so
i got a you know a massive watch
collection now and that community
is a very interesting global community
i've met some of the biggest collectors
in the world some of the princes in the
middle east
i'm friends with them now because you
know we were on whatsapp talking about
different watches it's a great community
to be
associated with and when we find a rare
piece you know everybody gets excited
about it and
it's just i don't know it's just
interesting i enjoy it
so what is it why are you doing it is it
literally just to get a watch
yeah you know it's a good question you
enjoy it i
i know you well enough at this point now
i know you enjoy this stuff i do right
but i'll tell you why i do it i tried
the other
way i took on my first big score the
sale of a learning company is a
4.2 billion dollar transaction including
the debt there were 10 of us as founders
we had all started with in middle class
or you know no money and
and we'd worked together for you know i
don't know 12 years or something
and then that was a massive liquidity
and i remember when we closed we were in
cambridge
and we were sitting around a table just
like this 10 of us you know having lunch
we ordered in some lunch to talk and we
closed the deal
so now we were funded and and i said to
every
what's everybody going to do i mean like
you know we're
they bought our company they don't need
us what are we going to do
and um how old are you at this point i
think i was uh
30 maybe early 30s
maybe 29. okay all right so around 30.
yeah around 30.
and um i said you know i'm going to take
i'm going to take uh
some time off i'm going to go to every
beach on earth
i just want to go to every beach on
earth including those ones in cambodia
vietnam
thailand you know these incredible
beaches the northern part of cyprus
these
all these legendary beaches and i did it
took me three years
and at the end of it i was bored out of
my [ __ ] mind i mean i just said
this sucks it was depressing this is it
this is all i do is go to beaches and
sit there and get drunk it's just boring
and i got back in the game i mean i just
got i started doing deals like crazy and
i put my capital work i became an
investor not an operator
i i made some great scores i made some
cat you know catastrophic failures
i lost millions i made millions and i
got in the groove and i figured out what
is it i'm good at
and you know um and then the shark tank
thing came along and that became a huge
platform
then the cnbc thing came along and it
kind of just morphed into this uh
you know like you know people know
exactly i'm pretty transparent not
everybody likes me they think i tell the
truth too much
about you know business i think it's
good but anyways it is what it is at
this point so i'm kind of
riding the wave looking for
opportunities shark tank guy renewed
yes thirteen got announced thirteen
seasons
i mean you know uh nobody can believe
what happened there
like nobody nobody um
i have another show i tape to telemundo
here in miami which will be announced
this week i'm excited about it but
you know what's going on to keep it a
secret until maybe next week i don't
know when
but telemundo is a i'll tell you i've
never been to that studio before
it is the most modern studio in the
world it's completely digital
the whole thing is wired digitally even
the signs are all digital they can
change
anything temperature in one part of the
room it's it's and it's massive when jlo
rehearsed for her super bowl act she did
it
in a sound stage there the size of a
football field wow and i was taping
right beside that when i and i went and
looked at it like this place has its own
weather zone it's so big the ceilings
were so high
yeah and it's just north of the airport
it's a massive facility
yeah shark tank 13th season versus
the first time you went on does it still
just as exciting is it still just as fun
or is it different now well
a few things have changed um
first of all venture capitalists have
now figured out that
they get to 100 million eyeballs for
free so you've got all these vc
back deals like with 50 million
valuations 100 million valuations
and my attitude about that is i don't
give a [ __ ] what your valuation is if
you want me as an investor i'm carving
my own deal
and you don't have to take it but it's
going to be that makes me
get i get a special position because i
add way more value than your vc does
nobody knows who your venture capitalist
is
they don't they don't know the brand but
who cares they're all the same
and they all want preference shares and
all this stuff and i'm not saying
they're bad people i love venture
capitalists but i don't need them
i can raise my own money for my firms in
my own way
and i don't like preference shares i
don't like shares that are sitting above
me and have rights i don't have that
just pisses me off so i don't use that
stuff
so we get a lot of those companies now
pump we got all these companies that
safe that only we could get on shark
tank right
so we get they have to weed a lot of
those out because they're just gold
diggers
then we get some really interesting
stuff on direct to consumer
like there's a trend emerging in america
let's just take the food
group for example low sodium low
sugar low cal totally healthy like
really eclectic verticals where people
you know that really care about health
will make a different kind of
coffee or a different kind of peanut
butter and what i find
what i what i see happen on those deals
is when they hit the airwaves
you sell five million dollars worth of
it in one hour
yeah a lot of people are into that
health thing so that's a big change that
because in the old days we just have
pizza sauce and you know just hot sauce
and
sauce and you know now it's sauce with
no sodium totally fresh
no preservatives all that kind of stuff
and things like that
and and really they come in knowing what
shark they want
they've known us so well now i want to
deal with you know
damon and clothing or you know i want to
do a financial thing with kevin or
whatever it is
in anything in the wedding industry
that's me i love love
uh i want to leave with the best story
from shark tank that you've ever told me
which is your best investment which is
the potatoes
yes tell us the story and what happened
uh
since you did this deal yeah
so it's called potato parcel and
it's a company i'm imagining damon being
here right now and just laughing his
head on he
and he did he did this guy comes on
and he says i take a potato a real
potato
and i you send me your image digitally
and i imprint
your face on the potato and then i ship
it
to somebody for you in the u.s mail
and then they put the potato with little
toothpicks
in a little thing of water and the
potato grows right through your face
and it and it takes months to do it and
crazy stuff happens right
i thought that's really really stupid i
mean that is
incredibly stupid and what a stupid
business this is
and he said well what is it you care
about in business sales right
and i said of course but nobody would
buy that crap and they said oh yeah look
at this
he had like 30 growth a month
and he was really good at seo he was
really good on on digital really good on
social he was telling the story
and i was sitting there thinking i'm
never going to invest in this thing so
stupid and i said to him well
how about i get a chunk of equity but i
want a royalty i want to
but hold on you'd already seen one
example of something stupid
make money right that's an important
part of this well it's true i saw
i want to draw a cat for you yes which
was the stupidest most stupid thing i've
ever seen which one's dumber
potato head or i want to draw drug half
using incredibly stupid you pay a guy
to draw a cat and then he mails it to
you
like and cuban invest in that made a
fortune i thought that was the stupidest
stupid because he had the song right he
like had something
to do with danced like a cat and it was
like so i thought it was such a piece of
trash what a stupid idea
and it did a ton and and really really
high margins because this guy would just
sit down and draw a cat and he had other
cat drawers
so dumb so when i saw the potato partial
i said there's room in my portfolio for
a potato parcel company
now remember on shark tank you calculate
you're putting out capital so you really
want the internal rate of return
on that capital in in really nas
adventure investing
it's return of capital not return on
capital you care about
that thing aired and i got my money back
in like 45 minutes
and so it has the highest return ever
for me and a shark
everything because i had a dollar
royalty on every potato and i own i
can't remember what percentage
i forget what i own to the company but
that thing
has has just spun cash and i got calls
from ceos of major corporations saying
listen i want to buy 1500 potatoes for
my sales force globally
and ship them and i want a discount i
say no way there's no discount i'm the
only kid in town
[Laughter]
monopoly on facebook nobody else puts a
face on a potato the way we can
plus our new gift box pump we get a
premium gift box
with a beautiful little label on it and
a gift package with your face in the
potato
and it comes to your door and you're
just thrilled to death we are pumping
those out by the hundreds of thousands
and there's no discount i mean this is
the el supremo potato
so there it just shows you with the
right social media platform
what you can do and and and these are
real entrepreneurs it's a real business
it's not a [ __ ] business
so it's made money it's a watch i'll
tell you that
i'm proud of you because three years ago
when i went on the cnbc set
and you hit me with you were forbidden
you're not at 50
yet yeah but uh you're at three
maybe five maybe you know you're headed
in the right direction yeah we are and i
think we could eventually get we may
we may abandon our gold position which
is significant we pay
the way we own gold is we own the gld
for rebalancing even though it's more
expensive it's very liquid
but we also store gold and pay for the
storage so we
it costs us money to hold an asset that
has no
yield and that's the argument that the
committee makes about the gold position
we've got
saying think about this it's reversed
interest if gold stays flat
it costs us to own it why don't we just
allocate
200 basis points of the gold portfolio
just sell down our glds
go to fiat and then just buy in you know
bitcoin
yeah or you know whatever you can you
don't have to just buy bitcoin but buy a
portfolio of different at
crypto you know crypto assets and then
do the contracts
and i'm i'm opening up to it um because
proof is in the pudding
and so it's just and you and the weird
thing is that
and you said it earlier you don't want
to go back to fiat
and so you're saying to yourself i'm
going to live with more and more of all
because you are as you build up that
asset but you feel a lot better about
getting
yield off it all of a sudden it's
working for you while you're sleeping as
opposed to
most people think they just own bitcoin
in their wallet pay their ridiculous
fees to their wallet which they don't
have to
i mean people are going to figure this
stuff out they're going to start to see
d5 can be a lot cheaper less
less friction you can still be compliant
i don't want to break any laws
i want to be compliant because i got a
lot of other assets and that's why i
want this version of what we're doing in
vancouver with the
you know the d5 ventures guys i want
that to be compliant to the point where
i just press a button to get my tax
return
you know that's how it works yeah i mean
it can so i'm very excited i mean
obviously you've been riding the wave a
lot longer than i have but but i'm
caught up pretty damn fast
you're coming along we just got to get
you to stop uh the other thing you said
one time was a crypto garbage
not garbage garbage which is a little
bit above garbage no but i liked it and
it's now legendary out there and
everybody nails me to the wall on that
thing
they say they say they say you're the
guy that called it garbage
i'm going to let you in a little secret
about the tv commercials that you see on
hulu roku sling tv
and other popular streaming services did
you know that these commercials are
completely
different for every household and these
ads can be targeted like you can't
believe
with my commercials i can target based
on a user's purchase
behavior their household income their
job title their location
i can even target based on if you
visited one of my websites or made a
specific purchase
these options are basically endless
it's probably starting to make a lot of
sense why you're seeing a lot of these
commercials these days
right unfortunately because of the huge
cost of tv advertising
most small and medium-sized businesses
have never been able to advertise in
this media
these ads haven't even been an option
until
now a company called c-squared social
has solved this
c-squared social is a company i'm
partnering with because of their
extraordinary connected
tv capabilities and best of all they're
the only ones in the business who have
no minimum spend requirements
if you aren't running these types of ads
you're crazy
you've got to meet these guys i love
innovation
i love entrepreneurs and i love tools
that help medium and small business
check them out c squared social
fantastic
hey kevin so you recently said on
coindesk tv that institutions esg
committees are in fact taking a harder
look at crypto assets specifically and
demanding better compliance
and of course that conversations only
heated up since then especially around
bitcoin so we'd love to know
what's your take on the current view in
esg in terms of the sector
you know it's it's a this is all a good
thing and i'll tell you why it shows you
that
the institutional allocation committees
and
sovereign funds and pension plans and
large institutions who really have
been ignoring crypto for quite a long
time i know we're all very excited about
it but the truth is that less than one
percent of institutions globally
actually carried as an asset class at
all so we're just at the
nascent beginning of this interest and
as you know
and it's been discussed quite a bit in
the last few weeks most of these
institutions have both ethics
and sustainability committees that
filter offerings before they're
allocated on the investment committee
and they're doing the same thing with
every asset they're not just singling
out crypto or bitcoin or ether
it doesn't matter they're doing it with
every asset and so the fact that they're
going through this process i consider
a very positive sign and now the we have
to find a voice the industry that mines
bitcoin specifically
needs to find a voice to talk about the
things they do that actually help
build sustainability into energy i mean
they
the obviously when you're mining coin
you want the lowest cost of energy you
can get and that makes you invest
capital
in finding it and finding sustainable
ways to have it
so that you can mine in the most
profitable you can the profit motivation
of
mining bitcoin is actually helping
sustainability but that voice is
lost in the criticism right now
particularly after new york
threatens to put that three-year
moratorium on bitcoin mining and then
you heard from elon and then all the
institutions chimed in
we have no voice miners have no voice
that's the problem currently
so kevin so a voice is part of this but
presumably there's some very specific
things that
whether it's miners or developers of
digital assets in particular
can do to try to ensure that they do
meet these demands of esg
investment committees what kind of
things should they be focused on
well if you're in kazakhstan burning
coal to make bitcoin
not so good that's obvious obviously
every sustainable committee is going to
say no we're not we don't want that
we've got to find a different way to do
it and i think a lot of the energy now
and there's more and more of this
conversation dialogue occurring
is to go to the institution itself and
say i'm a bitcoin miner
i have a sustainability mandate i am in
sync with you
i am going to mine my coin sustainably
here's my energy source here's how i do
it here's where i mine it
and you can buy my shares if i'm public
or in private you can invest in me and i
will hold that coin
on my balance sheet for you you will
know its providence you will know it was
mined ethically you will know it was
mine sustainably
and we together can build this business
together that's after you as an
institution decided to put three or five
or six percent
into bitcoin in the first place and
there's a lot of excitement about
bitcoin there's no question
it's the one that most institutions are
talking about even though
as a community the crypto community has
lots of other opportunities
right now the institutions are
interested in being exposed to the
volatility of
bitcoin but they've got to resolve this
problem and i think there's some very
interesting research going on now and
indeed
investments and i'm part of it to try
and find a way to tag a bitcoin
a coin itself that to prove that it has
a wrapper around it
that it came from a sustainable miner
and this sounds
out there but it's being worked on right
now because that's what institutions
want
and when that dam gets released the
amount of capital
that will come into bitcoin it'll be the
reason it goes to 100
000 200 000 and all the dreaming that's
been going on around price appreciation
that's not going to happen until
institutions start to buy it
so everybody's got to wake up and
realize there's demand but it's got to
be done
around esg concerns so to your point
there definitely are some really
exciting projects and data and high
quality research on these topics
but the reality is at least right now
the debate around bitcoin's carbon
footprint is really these it's
happening in these overly simplistic
talking points on both sides
and so some of us really believe there's
a critical need for more nuanced
sophisticated dialogue on what's
possible and what's not possible
what do you think can be done to help
shift the narrative
well the narrative is going to be
shipped by the market itself i mean
obviously there's a lot of
miscommunication and a lot of mistruths
about it
the fact that there are minors in china
and other places in the world iran iraq
you know kazakhstan etc that are not
really concerned about esg issues
because they've never had to deal with
it
but they're still profitable miners new
mining operations new investments in
mining are
very very let's call it hip to the issue
they get it and particularly if they're
going after institutional capital
there's many deals on the market right
now
that are trying to raise 100 200 300
million dollars to build out facilities
in a sustainable fashion
so it you know obviously this is a very
new issue it's probably only four months
old
but it's becoming a big cry from those
institutional investors
and the community itself there's many
different views there's no question
about it
but this issue is not going away that's
for sure and if you want to unlock as i
said earlier the power
of the institutional dollar the billions
and billions of dollars that would be
coming into bitcoin alone
if it was in a way that would be part of
the mandate for sustainability and
ethics
that's what really unlocks the power so
everybody that owns bitcoin today
regardless of how it was mined is
incentivized
to solve this problem for one reason
alone
price appreciation this is not brain
surgery everybody can figure this out
price and demand
and to to ignore it and to say oh it
doesn't matter is a huge mistake and i
think over time particularly over the
next 24 months is the new deals
every deal i look at now to invest in a
minor
just let's stay in the mining sector for
it for a moment it's the number one
question i have
how are you dealing with the esg issue
what is your plan to show institutions
that may want to own your stock down the
road
just to have exposure to your coin what
are you doing about it
are you taking off flared gas or you're
new a hydro facility for hydroelectric
are you going to new geographies where
there's very very sustainable low-cost
power
what's the plan and i'm glad we're
having the conversation i'm glad you're
focusing on it because it is a very big
deal
so it sounds like you think it's very
demand side driven do you think that
there's alignment
in these investors do you think that
they agree on what it is they want to
see
well you know it goes from a baseline of
don't burn coal don't do harm to
let's find the most profitable miner
that has found a way to get the lowest
cost energy contract i mean there's a
lot of differences between all of these
different offerings
but this issue we weren't even talking
about as a you know crypto community
just 11 months ago it wasn't on
anybody's radar screen and then all of a
sudden you started to hear it no matter
what direction it came from there's all
kinds of people talking about it but but
but i think it's not a bad thing at all
the challenge with a decentralized asset
like bitcoin is there's no central voice
there are thousands of participants but
there's no committee
there's no um for lack of a better word
lobby group that says no these are the
actual stats
this is the real information there's
lots of different tangents
but it's an industry that's so nascent
so new that it hasn't found a way to say
wait a second we're being accused of all
these incorrect
facts we're going to fix this we're
going to put out real information
in the end the truth is what matters
particularly if you're an institutional
investor
and you want to know the facts but i can
guarantee you at the institutional level
right now
whether it's sovereign or domestic
pension or anybody else around the world
they are listening to what government's
saying you know norway just pulled its
tax credits because they've got a lot of
concern at the
at the popular level the population the
people that live there are worried about
it
you've heard the same concerns out of
other geographies saying why are we
burning all this power to make uh you
know a currency
and there and there's no voice there's
nobody pushing back and i think this is
going to change over time either the
ceos of the large mining operations
will come together and say here are the
facts about what we do or
the the crypto community will somehow
take from a decentralized view
to a central one to address government's
concerns
at the state level at the federal level
and at the international level as well
bitcoin as an asset is here to stay and
now it's got to get
in sync with what institutions want
before they
buy it if you like that video wait did
you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe